time to stop insiders fighting for
insiders more of insiders fighting for
insiders time to stop insiders fighting
for insiders America First Love the
[Music]
flow
down friend still
[Music]
Qui
I woke up in my head
this I woke up
there I woke up in my head
this I woke
[Music]
up justone in the
makeone in
[Music]
the
M
[Music]
Club
if you could have found out what M Club
meant I bet it would have saved him no I
don't think so no Mr Morgan was a man
who got everything he wanted and then
lost it his obsession with wine overtook
him he was a Somalia all great drunks
say that
maybe mug Club was something he couldn't
get or something he lost in a drunken
stuper anyway it wouldn't have saved
anything the
wine I don't think any drink can save a
man's life no I guess mug Club is just a
piece of a jigsaw puzzle a missing
piece and I heard he was
gay well come on everybody let's get
this place cleaned
up
[Music]
throw that
[Applause]
junk
join mug club today for just $89
annually or go mug list for $9 a month
and get access to the entire mug Club
family including Nick talo Brian Kalen
the Hodge twins Mr guns and gear and of
course Alex Jones go to
louderwithcrowder.com mug club today or
you're
gay
[Applause]
[Music]
Str that's what I
know
that was a bipartison sip aggressive
don't start aggressively byar oh don't
start okay I'll just sit here
idly okay start all
right that's the theme of today's
program we sheduled it in in advance uh
little bit is bipartisan hey you guys so
let's just bring this up let's bring up
the top sheet really quickly the Senate
border Bill we're going to explain that
we're going to explain where it is by
the way before it goes to committee oh
yes because a lot of people think it's
already passed it's law and then once it
goes to the Senate and then it goes to
the house like this happens a lot where
the story then
reemerges and people don't necessarily
know where they are in the process this
is not going to make it through the
house just to be clear uh we're also
going to discuss uh Tucker Carlson yeah
and whether interviewing dictators uh
which he has not done uh with a nation
uh with which we are not at war is ever
appropriate spoiler alert it's been done
many many many times before and then
we'll also be talking about uh this new
woke kindergarten initiative that uh
well basically cost the schools more
money and lowered test scores oh good so
that's great progress I have a few
question we're going to ask you a few
questions today but um what do you think
when you hear Democrats come out and say
this is
bipartisan you think that's a good
[Music]
thing that's the Playbook watch you're
going to have this on on the news for
the next three four five days will
reemerge once it goes they're going to
say bipartisan Republicans your move
when they say bipartisan they mean uh
one of those things where uh everybody
loses just to be clear and notice the
closer you get to the top the fewer
people who are involved they're much
closer together someone like a Mitch
McConnell very very close to former Vice
President Joe Biden very different from
your local Representatives when you have
a wider sample MH wider sample size and
uh also what do you think about uh about
Tucker Carlson if he interviews Putin do
you think that's a problem and if you
know if you could spend one day with
Vladimir Putin and not be locked
up what question would you want to ask
assume you're Britney grinder where you
get off scottf
free for the Lord of War of War Merchant
of death merch of death yes Merchant of
death yeah no good trade good trade that
wouldn't even be a good trade in the
WNBA if there was a player named
Merchant of merchant O Death it wouldn't
even be a good trade if you got the
entire WNBA in exchange for this guy no
no I'm saying even if there was a player
Merchant O Death like there was that
good of a player which there isn't
because they're women yeah you mean you
mean a player that can dunk The Merchant
of death in the WNBA scores 12 points
exactly a whopping Landslide she's The
Merchant of death she can beat a a a
varsity
player varsity boys varsity boys yes
deal with all these death Miss death
Miss death nailed it we'll call it
manslaughter all right number two
Captain Morgan how are you oh and if at
any point today during the show which I
guarantee you you will see you will
this that's the YouTube dump onon head
on over to rumble because we don't want
to be on YouTube anyway Captain Morgan
how are you sir doing well how are you
irritated in third chair I'll answer for
you when you hear us you know him you
love him Friday March 1st he's going to
be in De Moine Iowa oh boy yeah de boy
one of the Quad Cities the Lesser quad
Josh firin thank you for your service
how are you corn Town we're
coming cor that's what I call De Mo I
call it corn Town well you know in
Indiana they have it says there it's
like Indiana where more than just corn
say welcome to Indiana it's
corn we're more than just show them the
corn and the sign's in a corn field yes
dang it Jerry they only want to see the
corn that's why they came here come on
dance with the one you brought yeah
we're the Huskers you brought corn a
different state now but Iowa's cool
we'll see you there yeah Iowa was Iowa
was
so come on no good people in Iowa great
wrestlers I did not enjoy my time in Bor
Brock P's from Iowa I don't know who
that is Brock P the quarterback of the
49 playing the Super bowl next week and
I am not doing that he exchanged cure
for people poop people that's true
switched yeah all right so this is
something we all want to watch and by
that I mean I was told to avoid this so
we would watch it on air fresh so I have
had to as as I've gone through the news
avoid like the plague do we have it up
and working yes okay good we had a
little mishap with our uh with our track
just the overlay thing so uh Nikki Haley
was on SNL okay and uh she made a cameo
I guess that was so bad uh that
everyone's and I was specifically asked
again like we said not to have you seen
it I did see it I wasn't asked I wasn't
asked not to watch it it's like he
shakes his Christmas presents before the
morning no I
saw I saw this more organically I did
that once when I was a kid I shook it
and I was like it's a power pen it was a
comedy it was one of those things in
comedy where they like what everyone's
on the phone hey man you got to see this
great comedy performance by presidential
candidate what the hell's her name again
is that how they talk to you by
presidential candidate yeah that's what
all my all my friends talk to me like
that yeah you have to see this this joke
from uh president prot temporum of the
what all right so this is Nikki Haley uh
potential future president of the United
States on SNL I told them that if they
would do this that South Carolina would
wrap their arms around them and take
care of them I now officially work for
you there is nothing that you can need
that we won't make sure that we deliver
sorry right clip here's the SNL clip I
was just curious what would you say was
the main cause of the Civil War um and
do you think it starts with an S and
ends with a
ly yep I probably should have said that
the first time and live from New York
it's Saturday
night God I didn't think moms could ruin
SNL even
more jeez why would you invite her on
what do you mean why would you invite
her on they want to have her on because
they they want to give her a boost you
know it was great for oh God God they
she I don't know if you watched you
didn't watch the whole thing obviously
no I didn't I thought I was going to see
the whole thing now I I didn't know
people still watch us we just we just
saw short version It's a longer clip but
they had uh someone doing Trump oh no so
someone's doing Trump and responding
yeah he's he's all right and uh he's
she's responding to that guy like
basically just talking to to Trump
mhm it was like like she the kind of
thing she wouldn't do in person right
yeah yeah the kind of thing she want
do in person and two that people don't
usually do in primary races right yeah
if when she gets in front of trump if
she ever does in debate she'll freeze
like a musical did with she did the same
with that's my whole point she will
never get the opportunity to do it to
Trump because she's not a serious
candidate she asked she said that onl
she said she said if you're not afraid
of anything why won't you debate debate
me that's what she said to Trump on SNL
and it's like oh oh yeah thanks SNL what
what that say I don't know I'm
busy winning I thought you said you
didn't watch it
that's probably pretty much what did
they did a good they did an all right
job with Trump but I don't know if you
know speaking of of winning we are
actually uh giving away a truck at cers
shop.com it ends February 29th yes sir
you can also win $10,000 in cash what is
it every uh every dollar is one entry
one entry right now it ends at the end
of this it's a leap year I didn't
realize that many you thought this is
fake you're not no we we've we've been
giving away stuff yeah yeah so there you
go now go shop let's move on to Tucker
Carlson well this week just yeah let's
set this up uh here is a lot of people
just want to I it's there's recycling of
outrage so I saw this I saw this this
weekend I was going all right so what's
happening is he's in Russia so people
are speculating he may interview
Vladimir Putin I'm going yeah but he he
said that like people were outraged a
long time ago when he said it on his Fox
News show years ago it's like January 6
when they recycle it and then they it's
like hold on a second but you already
said this it's just but it's it's it
doesn't matter now doesn't M even if
it's true it doesn't matter at this
point they they need it's not new to be
outraged again yeah exactly yeah we have
plenty of things to be outraged about
today we don't have to recycle stuff I
don't really feel like we get outraged
you get you get irritated with people
selling you out you know the American
people but we try and be productive and
offer actual Solutions but the left
outrage how could he interview Putin
yell at the TV post on X yeah that'll
get him yes that'll prove your point
sounds like they don't want him to find
something out it sounds like they don't
want anybody to do anything they don't
like at this point so this weekend
Tucker Carlson was spotted H in
Moscow oh no reporting oh he's at a
dinner table so then of course the
outrage from Bill Crystal who he was I
mean he's the closest thing like if you
were to take a if you were to take a
flaccid penis and turn it into a man if
you that's right Fairy Godmother like
you're a pumpkin and you're a flaccid
penis it would be Bill
Crystal well you get you want the wreck
penis you get Billy Crystal
[Laughter]
boner so Bill Crystal he says perhaps we
need a total and complete shutdown of
Tucker Carlson re-entering the United
States until our country's
Representatives can figure out what is
going on figured out turn the code to
Orange and then Adam kinzinger he's a
traitor always funny coming from an
actual traitor yes look in the mirror
sir yes so this is again like let me
just show you this clip this is 2021 and
and you can comment below is it is it me
maybe it's because I'm plugged in and so
I'm familiar with these stories I didn't
give this any more attention this
weekend until I saw it trending I'm
going well yeah I mean he's just in
Russia but he said he would interview
Putin do you guys not remember that like
this is not new so 2021 here he is where
he was talking on a show uh in a topic
about how the NSA had spied on him which
almost should be more that's bigger
that's a bigger more of the outrage and
said yeah I want to interview Putin I
wasn't embarrassed about trying to
interview Putin he's obviously
newsworthy I'm an American citizen I can
interview anyone I want and I plan to
but still in this cas case I decided to
keep it quiet I figured that any kind of
publicity would rattle the Russians and
make the interview less likely to happen
but the Biden Administration found out
anyway by reading my emails I learned
from a whistleblower the NSA plan to
leak the contents of those emails to
Media Outlets why would they do that
well the point of course was to paint me
as a disloyal American a Russian
operative been called that before a stoe
of the Kremlin a traitor doing the
bidding of a foreign adversary and by
the way he also discussed this with a
Swiss publication last year which is you
know it's Swiss so it's inconsequential
so you may have missed this he said I
tried to interview Vladimir Putin in the
US government stopped me so think about
that for a minute and uh by the way
nobody defended me hold on a second we
did yep we did just to be clear just to
make sure now before we move on first
off we do have some exclusive footage by
the way that is new that is of Carlson
um out of
Russia
he's getting some weight the man can't
athletically dance but he's going to
beat 18 stuntman he was my action movie
hero until I I knew
better was that Anastasia on
Ice he's just swatting mosquitoes off oh
man so what kind of macara was
that gu's a clown so bad uh but here he
is actually I guess the Russians
actually seem pretty H happy to have uh
tuer Carlson there in in Moscow my name
is uh Alex I like you thank you you're
the best American journalist thank you
thank you where are you from uh I from
Moscow I
love thank you thank you it's really yes
yes what do you do in Russia I just want
this
so I wanted to talk to people and look
around and see how it was doing and he
doing very well I think uh maybe
interview
Putin an outrage the most offensive part
of that clip is that he's dressed like a
lesbian at a an animal house
quot I'm not getting into his fraternity
no no absolutely not this is let's think
about this for a second okay he said he
wanted to interview Putin can you find
the clip where he says that hey not only
do I support Vladimir Putin as a
dictator but I also support all of his
individual actions in other words you
could let's say you don't interview a
dictator all right that's one that's one
level you do interview a dictator but
you completely disagree with this person
and you think that their impact in the
world is fascinating let's go a step
further you interview the dictator and
you think that they maybe have some
redeeming qualities which is how they've
ascended to the position of being a
pseudo dictator oligarch if you want to
use that term while disagreeing with
some extreme actions that they've taken
okay now we're at level three they want
you to believe that he's a level four
where he's interviewing Putin because he
loves everything that he's done and he
supports totalitarianism how did we get
there and hey if we're talking about
totalitarianism how about the government
spying on him and them targeting him
making the US President coming in and
making sure that he cannot interview
exactly a US Jour head of St exactly a
US journalist that this is a newsworthy
individual whether you like him or not
Hitler would have been a newsworthy
individual yeah that's right time named
him person of the year I believe so
apparently that's that kind of is okay
but him going over there and talking to
him oh it's because it's not zalinsky
right they only want people talking to
zalinsky so they can get zinski when
he's at his new million do mansion in
Florida well no it's hard to catch him
there because he has to take the private
jet back over to I think somewhere on
the South Side you know the
Mediterranean France something like that
yeah so well he has to get there to
practice chopsticks with his penis no
he's got that down yes he does him and
Bill Bill Crystal just does it with his
head by the way they've already released
an image of the interview with Putin um
for the teasing I guess should say the
possible interview yeah
[Music]
teasing I I love how we had to photoshop
Tucker in that but we immediately had a
usable picture of Vladimir Putin wow
state issued picture yeah huh he had
just ridden a bear up to the stream
actually there's probably there's
probably like 14 images they had to go
through yes which one do you want he's
dude he loves taking photos of himself
like natural phot yeah he's the oligarch
influencer look at this I put I put my
back leg front in turn around so you can
see s he's got a couple couple AB
showing too a little bit if you give at
the right angle you might catch a little
that's right this is look it's not all
oligarchs who have a dump
truck the oligarch with the most that's
it my old man floppy milkshake bring all
the uh dissidents to prison
oh so it's a reference to mids mids R&B
song I hate you so let's go through the
standard though again now I don't I
don't agree I've had so many people I
would not want to be blamed for the
people who I've had on my show with whom
I vehemently disagree right I mean
there's there have been countless from
transgender mayors of small towns to
actual Senators that I don't even like
yeah or we have Congressman Senators
Mayors we've had uh we've had person
we've had show host there are plenty of
people who I interview I don't agree
with uh I understand that there's a
certain point where if you're
platforming someone act someone's actual
ideas and you don't challenge them so I
would say this there would be some
discussion warranted if Tucker Carlson
were to have sit down with Vladimir
Putin and it was just a fawning puff
piece like the mainstream media does
with former Vice President Joe Biden I
would say okay well you haven't really
held him to account uh and I also
understand how that's difficult to do
because they control the Press there
yeah exactly there are many levels that
we would have to go through for this to
even prove remotely a problem yeah and
and look I there are people that shill
all the time like Jackson hle shills for
China there's people that shi for North
Korea to make them seem like Niki Haley
for China Niki Haley for China a lot of
those people do that but has Tucker
Carlson ever really been a shill for
anybody he has some opinions maybe that
you don't like he Praises some countries
for some of the policies that they have
on the border that maybe you don't like
I think some most of them are fine by
the way but he doesn't come across to me
as a shill for anybody like he's just
going to be like oh Vladimir Putin
everything's great in Russia right
fantastic Fant it seems like he's going
to go over there and ask some maybe
difficult questions but it's probably
not going to push too much he's in
Russia he want to end up in prison for a
vape pen you kind of lose your leverage
when you're in the country of an true
you need to let them come to a neutral
country yeah that's like the Swiss
publication yeah so let's go through
this again uh the applying the double
standard because interviews with actual
dictators not that Putin is a dictator
right n he has proxies and he okay and
then he kind of stepped back and we had
uh we had someone who was another
president for a period of time and that
was cute so
actual dictators where you're talking
about completely unfitted and people who
are actually enemies uh to the United
States this has happened a lot and all
references are available at L credit.com
so the Ayatollah Kaman was interviewed
in 1979 by Mike Wallace uh hey remember
Castro yeah that guy remember Fidel
Castro yeah remember Socialist Communist
re revolutionary following the footsteps
of uh of CHA who killed black people and
gays and executed them without trial and
destroyed a beautiful island 90 M south
of Florida and bragged about it in front
of the UN so that you could put it on a
rage the machine t-shirt while the lead
singer supports Barack
Obama they are the machine it's insane
so Castro was interviewed in 1959 CBS
face uh the nation 1977 Barbara Walters
on ABC 1993 by Diane Sawyer you know who
else was interviewed by John Miller of
ABC in 1998 talk about platforming Osama
Bin Laden that one's kind of a biggie I
know what you'll say hey hold on a
second we weren't officially at war with
Osama Bin Laden in 1998 we're not at war
with Russia either just to be clear yeah
I'd like all involvement to be gone but
yeah we're not involved wasn't he on the
the most wanted list I think I believe
he was on the most wanted list because
at that point either that or he's
climbing the charts one the two he's
either there or he's number one most
wanted for interviews huh taking calls
someone got a nice scoop mamar Gaddafi
or uh Brown Jeffrey Ross if you see a
picture yes can you guys bring up side
by side Gaddafi Jeffrey
Ross oh my gosh you mean when he
traveled here to uh to New York he
stayed in a tent house to stay in a tent
and by the way that was in 2009 by Larry
King yeah why did no one ever come down
on Larry King this not only did he
interview G he was ill-prepared he's
like so Gaddafi
French why do you look white yes you
know you look like a friend I had
Jeffrey Ross part of him natural curls
he's the roast Master General
roastmaster gets a little bit uh a
little bit edgy but I find him funny
he's a Jew like me what eat for
breakfast
what so sorry then you have Bashar uh B
Al alisat let's just say Alis no one's
on a first name base with Bill Ney Neely
in 2016 NBC just to be clear and then
there was this gy of an interview also
with uh al-assad uh I guess if you're
gonna if you're going to comment below
who's the most useless journalist who
you can think of in the last 20 years or
30 years would it be Barbara Walters
yeah would it be the lady who turned
journalism into inconsequential
with if you could be a tree what kind of
tree would you be Barbara Walters who
can't even speak the language without a
speech impediment or would it be uh
wheel him out because he doesn't even
know where he is and he should have
retired a long time ago but he's
clinging to his power Larry King I don't
know which one but this was the standard
of Journalism I'm sorry these were the
carrier uh carryovers from the Golden
Era and I've been asking this if there
was a golden age of Journalism please
tell me when I don't buy it I just think
you didn't know about it here's the gem
with Barbara Walters and al-assad in
2012 I believe we were free to ask any
questions bashad al-assad is a dictator
by accident a mild mannered
opthalmologist he studied medicine in
England and found himself thrust into
the role of being Syria's leader after
the deaths of his dictator father and
older brother he insisted to me that he
has the support of much of his country
but not many others believe that ah ah
let me me Barbara can I do it do you a
favor sweetheart let me let me correct
something real quick I know that's
patronizing I meant to be he's not a
dictator by accident he's the leader of
the country by accident di the dictator
part was a choice yeah the dict he could
have gone in and been the leader of the
country by accident people got killed
before him now he's thrust into a
position of power he could have chosen
to not be a dictator yeah you just
answered I mean you just it doesn't
really require Columbo you're like his
father was also a dictator so and his
brother was murdered too yes oh everyone
I don't believe everything he say I
don't know he's sounding more she's
sounding more more I do not
believe everything other says but I got
interview so these are good light up
shoes I'm Baba yay typically speaking
the language appropriately is a
prerequisite to speaking professionally
uh which one that is unbelievable by the
way is this is in the 2016 interview I'm
I'm just trying to remember was that
before or after he had crossed the red
line by using chemical weapons on his
own people and you still interviewed him
so that's okay somebody who uses
chemical weapons on their own people and
the president said that's a red line for
us and if you do that oh boy didn't do
anything by the way I mean that's
another story they still went
interviewed this person it's totally
fine well he says he never did
that it was a accident he swore on a
Bible looking
back what' you say may have a I wrote it
down
yes right before I was hunting webbit we
do the side by side that you requested
jeffre Gaddafi and Jeffrey Ross there it
is you got him in the Rose Master outfit
too I don't know maybe I should go in
here and roast
ran that's awesome
perfect and uh I don't if if I were to
interview uh uh Putin I also understand
it may be useless because you can't
actually ask the questions especially on
own turf but you know what Putin May
provide some perspective hey you know
you might want to ask him about uh about
his plans with Ukraine if he plans on
crossing over into actual NATO Nations
you might want to ask him his thoughts
on the United States on his problems
with the United States on what he what
he actually sees as a vision for Russia
and what would actually allow us to
here's the thing there can be horrible
countries on the face of the Earth and
you don't have to go to war with them I
don't know do you hear that that's the
sound of slavery still going on across
the the African continent in Asia right
now we're not at war with all of them
just to be clear so you you can maybe
ask these questions and find something
fruit you can live on a planet with
horrible Nations and not be at war with
them yeah
yeah but if we interview him then how
are we supposed to make up things that
he thinks exactly good point how we
supposed to make up reasons to fight him
right yes that's exactly what I was
going to say right now what you've seen
is a complete silencing of one side and
look I don't agree with that side I
understand that I I think most of what
he's going to say is going to be
propaganda I get that but the only way
to ensure that you're getting propaganda
is to only listen to one side right
especially in this case when you've got
zalinsky going and making the rounds to
literally every country that he can
himself out to and then not
listening to anything coming from Russia
if at at at best maybe all it does is
make you a little bit firmer in your
convictions and by the way this would
all exist in a vacuum if it weren't for
the fact that the
bipartisan immigration Bill provides
another 60 billion to Ukraine so again
if you're talking about a if you're
talking about a country who's heads of
state uh where you have former Vice
President Biden and his son right you're
talking about illegal dealings with
Ukraine not only Ukraine but let's just
talk about Ukraine right here when
you're talking about barisma you're
talking about him sitting on an energy
company's board despite having no
experience Hunter Biden and kicking back
to the big guy and now providing What's
the total number up to if you look at
what's pledged well over 100 billion if
this bill were to be passed to Ukraine
well well well over while silencing the
opposition what was that 40 million oh
no that was the money that was stolen by
the five guys that were leading oh
military Ukraine oh sorry that was wrong
number yeah it's tough it's tough to
keep track well it's like weapons
Mercedes weapons Mercedes I don't know
you know it's like how do you figure
that out what if you need a new Yamaha
piano with shallower keys it's like just
go Honda baby it's
cheaper so this is where there's a lot
of good that can come of this they want
to silence that really does worry me you
can't interview Putin and we're pledging
hundreds of billions of dollars to
Ukraine that should worry everybody at
this point either you need to be neutral
or you need to be out in the open m and
this government should have no say in
what any members of the press or let's
say press let's also say podcasters now
at this point you look at what Jens saki
was doing with Joe Rogan that's the
concern the concern is reaching a point
where only one side is able to speak
which we have seen in the past by the
way also Rumble got in trouble for
allowing Russia Today to be on their
platform remember that was that the
French government or was that the
they've been in trouble with so many
governments the French government I
think it was the French government who
actually someone can bring this up they
banned them yeah from operating or from
people reaching Rumble I believe in
France over Russia Today yep by the way
we know uh CEO not pro Putin just to be
clear no absolutely he's Pro free speech
he's Pro these stuff that Putin is not
pro in fact right so anybody who tries
to silence him including Brazil they
just pulled out of Brazil I'm also
hearing right now that uh actually
Tucker is interviewing Putin in Russ we
have a clip
[Applause]
okay it's webbit
season stop making me
laugh by the way you know what that guy
he's such a piece of he he he holds the
carrot like a
ceremonial like it's a sword I could
kill you five times with this carrot I
chose not to thought he was holding like
something else but yeah go ahead sword
he also claims he's never gotten plugs
or dyed his hair yeah yeah wow roughly
170 is that including the 60 billion
from the border including the 60 billion
it's 170 roughly that's pledged which of
course has not been pledged I'm just
saying if they would have their way it's
happening at this exact same time insane
is it a conspiracy do you honestly
believe that this government who has a
vested interest in this Perpetual War
does they're not making some phone just
making a few phone calls to stir up
outrage regarding Tucker Carlson
interview interviewing Putin exactly is
that a cons genuinely comment below do
you think that's an actual conspiracy at
this point when Jens saki says Joe Rogan
and Spotify uh we really hope that
spotifly as she said you know does their
due diligence and doesn't allow
misinformation to spread do you really
think that that's a conspiracy at this
point and I have there would be no love
lost for Putin just to be clear yeah I
just don't know at what point people say
it's a conspiracy or you're being
paranoid we see it happening yeah no
it's an actual censorship yes it's an
attempt of censorship it's not I get not
like fine you canot like it that fine
you don't want to hear from a dictator I
get it but for somebody like Adam
kenzinger put aside the fact that I
think Adam kenzinger is one of the worst
Representatives that we have ever had he
had the footage of January 6 and said
they were terrorist he no what he did is
he lended credibility to a committee
that has put people in jail and caused
people to commit suicide because they've
gone after them with terrorist charges
yeah instead of just trespassing charges
that's you Adam kininger just so you
know blood's on your hands my friend but
he comes out to say he's a traitor right
how you canot like it all you want but
is he is he aiding our enemy we're not
at war with those guys so I'm not sure
how you come up with the traiter thing
but you're very quick to jump on X and
be like ha traitor because he's doing an
interview how does that make any sense
Adam go away he fought when you said you
weren't going to be in public life
anymore that meant we didn't have to
hear from you anymore and apparently
that's not true hey actually Tim's
telling me we have we have Adam kiter on
the phone he's oh good oh jeez he's
ready to answer jl's questions by the
way do we call in bro it's pronounced
tweo TW TW I'm from the school of
Barbara Walters pisses me off by the way
you can join M Club we'll be doing a
whole segment today on the woke
kindergarten initiative which is
hilarious hey we have a we have a little
petri dish uh it doesn't work and uh
it's $89 annually you get the hand
etched of course hand painted mug or you
know you can go muglet for $9 right now
but you don't necessarily you're not a
full member of the mug Club but we
understand that times are tough or sorry
the best economy ever best economy
according to the former vice president
uh so do for we're doing good I have
enough money I can buy a new W Walo wal
oh wal fire what does she do with W's
she just go she just replace it with
something else like too no idea what to
do freezes yeah can't say her own last
name barbar I guess he had a one and 26
shot of getting it right
so let's go through the Senate 25 cnk
are the same oh yes true that's yeah
Canadians say Zed that's DB I know I was
chastised is that what you said yeah I
what is that what you Z that's what I
said I see what you did there what is I
thought Z which makes no sense what is
that supposed to be z z oh oh that does
make no sense yeah I know okay it makes
abs and I was sent to the office because
I said no that's wrong teacher and I
went through a b CDE e f g h i j k l o p
QR s t u v WX Y and Zed you're
it makes no sense this is a stupid
country and you color with a
uell yes I would to be your teacher all
right let's go to the Senate border bill
so this is something right now let's
let's just kind of clear this up uh
where we are so the Senate unveiled it's
like this $111 billion 118 sorry $18
billion sorry that's all going to the
Border yes the bipartisan uh it's it's
complete garbage so this is going to be
voted on most likely this week right
we'll probably talk about the Senate
then of course it really is very
unlikely to make it through the house
because you will see this outrage
recycled and they don't necessarily
inform you as to the actual legislative
process I know that a lot of you know
this but I can't tell you how many times
we get people sending in chat going now
that this border this new border bill is
law no it's it's it's it's not it's very
unlikely to be what you currently see uh
in its final form and this is not new
this is remedial I know some of you are
are new here we went through this with
with Barack Obama we're talking about
dreamers right and if there was
something on my desk I would sign it
tomorrow when the left says bipartisan
when they all of a sudden say hey we
need partisanship what they mean is they
need to get what they want and if you
don't go along then you're you're no
longer compromising that you are
unreasonable the label you the party of
no that's what this is okay and by the
way speaker Johnson been impressed with
him he said that the the bill is DOA if
it makes to the house so let's just show
you really quickly to give you some
context here and uh then we'll give you
some numbers on the spill but again the
theme is bipartisan it's bipartisan it's
bipartisan this is great it's bipartisan
it's bipartisan so they can say look
Republicans won't sign the B the
bipartisan Bill extremists MAA basket of
deplorables so stop with the idea of
saying I'm a compassionate conservative
we talked about that last week stop
saying I'm a moderate conservative
because if you don't go along with the
bill that provides hundreds of billions
of dollars to Ukraine Israel to Wars
that has nothing to do by the way with
immigration then you'll be labeled an
extremist I I think that that would
literally Encompass everyone from
Libertarians to Maga
Republicans or extremist uh as they call
it here's Schumer uh feasting on a child
no sorry discussing yeah different
all right good evening everybody watch
so after four months of
difficult diff let me say again after
four years of difficult four
sorry ladies and gentlemen after four
months of long Jewish difficult
negotiations I am really proud and
pleased to announce that Democrats and
Republicans in the Senate have come to
an agreement on the bipartisan
supplemental bill tonight this bill is
vital vital to America's future your
interests we fix the Border problem in
this bill when have you ever heard Chuck
Schumer say what uh a surprising number
of conservatives have come up is vital
never that's what I want you to pay
attention to it's a slight of hand when
they say we're when they call for
bipartisanship it means they want you to
shut up and then when they're in power
of course they're never bipartisan just
to be clear but for some reason so many
Republicans have allowed themselves to
be Lael the party of no and a big reason
is because of people like the Mitch
McConnells of the world who are empty
suits
uh oh that's not fair that's not fair to
say about my my uncle mcon my turkey FN
Lake that's not fair I said I said he's
a Kentucky man and I'm a Kentucky man
too that's right a man learns to play
baseball you couldn't do any of that
stuff this cartoon now if you don't
learn to play I say I say I put this
young boy in a
dress what what I think I heard me no by
the way this guy saying bipartisan is
vital let's just for context this is the
kind of stuff that you have heard
Schumer say when he's not trying to act
as though he's a reach across the aisle
prick Republicans and only Republicans
are holding everything up because of
unrealistic maximalist demands on the
border and millions of American women
are having their rights ripped away by a
magga hard right Supreme Court days away
once again from a government shutdown
all at the hands of this endless Maga
Madness Republicans played a dangerous
and risky partisan game and I am glad
that their brinksmanship did not work we
saw we even saw Maga extremist bring all
of Congress to a grinding halt for more
than a month so just keep in mind magga
extremist when you're talking about the
dobs case which allows states to
regulate abortions so you can still have
a 32- we abortion and and do in places
like California and places like Colorado
that's so extreme that he calls you
effectively a domestic terrorist so when
when he says bipartisan and vital you
know it must be really bad yeah and I
hitney the same guy who stood in front
of the Supreme Court when it happened
and said that they will reap the
Whirlwind yes and basically threatened
not only the justices but anybody that
agreed with the justices which was the
entire Republican party yep I think
that's the same guy yeah also speaking
of guys we don't like this uh Mitch
McConnell had this to say about the bill
I am grateful to Senator Langford for
working tirelessly to ensure that
supplemental National Security
legislation begins with a direct an
immediate solution to the Cris
at our Southern borders so hit the like
but time now every time you talk you
have to use that voice for hit the like
button if you want to see McConnell in a
nursing home or in a cartoon well I
don't think you can afford to put I
don't I see I see I see you got to have
you got to come you got to come with
like you have the the neck fat what's it
called a um J yeah you have like you
have a j we'll just yes we'll tell them
it's a nursing home this
isos he and he'll respond by going like
this yes exactly for four minutes and
all is well and notice the closer you
get to the top the more like they become
there was an exception president Donald
Trump some people call him former
president some people calling sitting
president I call him sitting president
okay sitting so that's why they can't
stand the guy and there are other
reasons to not be able to stand him but
look at you look at the grahams and the
McConnell's and then the bidens and then
the Schumer of the world you go oh okay
that's where you think the game is
rigged I've traveled this country
thousands of people in every never once
never once met a Mitch McConnell fan
that's how you know these people are
effectively coronated they're not
necessarily elected yeah all right so
let's go through the claims with this
bill all references are available at
lc.com Link in the sidebar the
claim is that this is a bipartisan bill
right so let's go through this really
quickly the bill was drafted by uh
Christian Cinema in Arizona uh Chris
Murphy Jim
Langford wait wouldn't there be a lot
more no well uh wouldn't there be a lot
more no I thought hold on a second how I
thought we were talking about this is Oh
you mean it's not drafted by the whole
no the Senate votes on it ah oh wait so
it's bipartisan voted but uni party
written pretty much they say like ah
toss an r on there a Democrat a
Republican and independent that's where
you can stack the deck it's like
conducting a trial a clinical trial and
you somehow alter the sample group or
the place the control group right this
is why there are standards to certain
trials and studies being admitted so
sure I guess it's bipartisan
that's not representative of the voting
base to be clear in the Oklahoma GOP
even the house or even the house they
censored Langford for support of this
bill yeah and this is what you see
Democrats they create a problem they
draft bipartisanship legislation they
get a handful of rhinos to sign on and
then they shame actual conservatives
other Republicans for not passing the
bill so they're going to be saying
bipartisan until of course this thing
gets stonewalled for valid reasons which
we'll get to and then say look at the
extremists so we'll get to the details
but just remember that I'm calling it
right now bipartisan bipartisan by
partisan except for the extremists well
you're talking about just a you're
talking about you can count on one hand
you could count on one flipper hand if
you were like the twin who didn't get
the placenta a the amount of people
who's that who's that one rep from
Oklahoma what was his name Langford
Langford yeah he's sitting there like
I'm one of the good ones
yes I'm I listen to him talking about it
he generally thinks that this is a good
idea yeah I know like ah this is
terrible well it's cuz he can't read
well come on now we don't want to be
literacy
it's true here's another example that we
talked about well you know let me just
show you so you can believe your lying
eyes and ears here's Barack Obama in
2013 blaming the government shutdown on
a handful of extreme by the way let's
just be clear shutdown means that
everyone's pushing for something and
then some other people say no no we
don't agree so a shutdown is a natural
consequence of the process all of a
sudden the shutdown just becomes about
people who don't want to spend hundreds
of billions of dollars on useless
and by the way we're not spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
useless you complain about how we
need hundreds of billions of dollars for
books or improving schools no you need
them for more bombs just to be clear
what point are there enough bombs and by
the way I'm someone who supports the
fact that we have nuclear weapons I
think it's good keeps Russia at Bay like
hey what are you doing Iran we see what
you're doing right we're flicking the
jab out I understand that but do we
really need another $60 billion pledged
to Ukraine right now hey if that's not a
valid reason taking hundreds of billions
of dollars from Americans or as they
refer to it aing air to provide it to
foreign Nations so they can build or
purchase weapons likely purchasing them
from giant American Military contractors
then what would be a valid reason for a
government shut down does it have to be1
trillion for more bombs and this is why
the whole electorate the idea of
Republican and Democrat is switching not
that I'm a moderate but that you see too
many Republicans lining up here and
allowing the Democrat Playbook to
continue through the progressive left
Playbook which by the way is
anti-American and it's anti it's
anti-human just to be clear so here's
Barack Obama in 13 blaming the
government shut down on extremist
Republicans good morning everybody at
midnight last night for the first time
in 17 years the republicans in Congress
chose to shut down the federal
government oh let me be more specific
one faction of one party in one house of
Congress in one branch of
government shut down major parts of the
government good all because they didn't
like one law Republicans in the house of
Representatives refused to fund the
government unless we defunded or
dismantled the Affordable Care Act
yes Obamacare for the uninitiated and by
the way nothing has been a greater
Kickback to insurance companies than
Obamacare look at the premiums look at
your deductibles look at what it has
done for American Healthcare you can
only get ObamaCare you can only get on
that in that insurance Market if you are
basically below the poverty line uh and
of course it's very difficult to do if
you're a middle- class American who
actually pays taxes you are getting
screwed by that bill and paying more for
healthcare there's been nothing more
corrosive to American Healthcare than
Obamacare to be clear wish they would
have shut it down longer yes and held
out more yes right by the way at least
we're spending you know hundreds of
millions if not billions of additional
dollars every single year and and still
not solving the problem of the uninsured
which was the whole thing exactly yeah
like oh there's 50 million uninsured
Americans how many are there now like 48
million yeah 48 million yeah turns out
we we we miscalculated on that a little
so you know maybe shut down in
retrospect yeah progress that's one for
you good idea now uh former Vice
President Biden did the exact same thing
in 2023 and he blamed extreme
Republicans for not passing what was
this another and just to be clear
another spending
Bill let me ask you this okay if you're
watching right now and you're a
progressive leftist or you vote
Democrat because the answer for the
Democrat Party at least for the last and
I'm willing to bet pretty much ever but
certainly for the last four or five
decades is no when is it ever okay to
substantially cut
spending in other words it's been
increase increase increase increase
increase that's just the default and so
when they say Republicans actually want
to gut no hold on a second how about
sometimes there have been shut Downs
just because they want to increase by
less yep is there ever a time where you
finally say you know what maybe reducing
government spending we've been going One
Direction Forever let's maybe try
another one because schools haven't
improved with the Federal Department of
Education if you look at uh you look at
our qu you look at our quality of life
right here in the United States
certainly over the last 3 years it has
not improved you look at infrastructure
has not improved but you don't
necessarily think things are getting
better certainly you're not seeing that
money that you're spending more and more
being taxed more and more and I also
don't know why we need to be taxed at
this point you can just print more money
so why tax any of it none of this is
real is there ever a point comment below
is there ever a point and this is a
genuine question to the Democrats out
there is there ever a point where you
would say you know what maybe we need to
cut spending a little
bit because if you believe that you are
what what according to former Vice
President Biden and the entire DNC an
extremist
Republican just a few months ago the
speaker of the house and I agreed to uh
spending levels uh for the government we
were up right to the very edge almost we
make down our debt Obama made sure to
make the letters big for fund essential
priorities and still cut the deficit by
$1 trillion over the next decade now
small group group of extreme House
Republicans they don't want to up to
that deal and everyone in America could
be faced with
a paying the price for that and of
course we uh fact checked that we did a
whole segment I would not actually cut
the deficit just to be clear hey the
deficit means that you're spending far
more than you actually have right that
then the debt is the cumulative right so
over 10 years if you believed this claim
you'd maybe reduce the deficit mean
you'd still spend way more than you
actually bring in uh but you know that
would well that that would be better
than where we well hold on a second
though but the debt so in other words
we're still growing the debt by
trillions every single year yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah still a bigger tab
well then you're not really solving the
problem are you no we're just making it
less worse but we're buying votes oh
that's right you you're not taking it
we're buying votes yeah and you made
this point but I I think most and you
guys can fact check me out there I think
most of the government apparent
government shutdowns or problems they've
had with spending bills have not been to
cut spending it's been to cut the growth
of spending right it's saying instead of
growing by say 3% we do one and a half
or two versus four or something like
that every single one that I can
remember where there has been a fight
over the last 20 years it's been because
of that not cutting actual spending
right that's insane this is why you want
someone who's actually had business
experience there because you don't just
say hey uh by how much are we going to
increase our costs every single year
with the business sometimes you actually
have to scale back yes that's what
happens in a marketplace with the
government you never do 20 some odd 30
trillion I don't even know how many were
in debt right now Lane says I'm correct
by the way I'm not always correct on
that stuff but I'm correct here
trillions of dollarss in debt at what
point you're like we can't we can't pay
that yeah the government has been
collecting more in Revenue than ever
just to be clear and it doesn't really
matter so much if you increase taxes or
you decrease taxes it ends up being that
you know that's housers law that we've
talked about between 16 and 20% no
matter what just because of inflation
just because there's more money right
now people uh are actually giving more
to the government than ever before and
it hasn't it hasn't fixed anything zero
impact I wish the government would uh
would care about their shareholders yes
good no us come on well they do it's
called the initial uh the initial Social
Security beneficiaries those are the
ones they need those votes so they don't
want to solve that problem either it's
about buying votes they're generating
Revenue so they can buy votes here's
some more proof for you let's go through
the actual contents of the Bill here's a
claim that they'll make that the Border
bill here is going to solve this
Invasion problem uh the truth just to be
clear um it won't
so simple just changes the wording yeah
yeah just to be how do I know well one
of the co-sponsors Chris Murphy uh
actually stated on x the Border never
closes well there it is now I don't need
to say anything else to you it won't
solve the
problem because the Border mom never
closes but that was that was one of the
things right and we'll get into the
numbers here in a second but it gives
the the president of United States the
ability to close the border if it
exceeds 5,000 Encounters in seven days
right so seven days in a row 5,000
encounters and I'm like let's just
assume for a fact for a minute that
that's a good idea yeah you can close
the border how right what are you going
get the United States armed forces and
station them along the border you
haven't been good at closing the border
now yeah 34,000 cross problem it's just
saying it that's what it is exactly it's
we'll close the border it's well can you
just say it's closed CU well well the
beauty is he we talking about
hypotheticals because again co-sponsor
of the bill Chris Murphy stated the
Border never closes so I don't need to
say anything
else but I will can I call them 24 hours
or yeah exactly he's like 7eleven they
have rep oh yeah all the time ready to
go so let me give you some more now if
you think you can solve the Border
crisis with the most amount of Border
interactions or I guess apprehensions
depending on the Met it was 304,000
right more than ever was that was that
uh Mar was that was December that's
right before that was March of last year
September no September no no that was a
record before September was a record and
then December was another record okay
before that it was March then went down
a little bit the migrant numbers in
December yes I do there a lot Crossing
in September
election in
no so let's look at more in the bill but
the Border never closes if you have a
hole in your boat you got to plug the
hole first yeah but the bill mandates
that the uh the DHS secretary um can uh
you know activate emergency Authority
only when during a period of seven
consecutive calendar days there's an
average of 5,000 or more aliens who are
encountered each day or on any one
calendar day a combined total of 8,500
or more aliens are encountered so again
if that's just if it doesn't cross the
threshold so let's say you go 1 2 3 4 5
six okay six days we had over 5,000 but
then day seven you hit 4,999 it resets
what if a guy misses the clicker I mean
come on the guy Costco's counting these
guys or
exactly even if it averages out to be
more than 5,000 a day but one day is
lower but let's just take the math and
say really conservative all right it's
only 4,900 99 today that would still be
1.8 million illegal immigrants Crossing
per year that's nothing that we
encounter these are not the people that
we don't see or stop and by the way the
total under Donald Trump his presidency
was 1.9 million oh so they want to those
are rookie numbers we want to pump those
up yeah I wonder if that number is
larger or um smaller than our current
military numbers it's a good point oh my
gosh I know the answer you do I'm
betting it's terrifyingly smaller it is
terrifying no the the the military
smaller
overrun we'll just conscript these guys
and military service there we go just be
overrun by bumblebee
bodies bumblebee bodies like
Transformers or like Mexican
leadi all the above oh I am Optimus
Prime I your G you're so off to me
Soo let combine both worlds Josh come on
good job
jald Mark wallberg is no I'm not going
to do dubbing okay I'm going to do it in
real time let's do two Tes I'll do it in
Japan don't
bumblebee huh you want to cross the
border cross the huh if I was watching
the board I wouldn't got down like that
okay where's Megan Fox she's not in this
movie I was told it's going to be a hot
girl in this movie I there was Megan Fox
there was a blonde one and the second
one we never saw her again why don't you
bring her back she's not doing anything
so she was your daughter in the movie
was she no no she wasn't she was the hot
one from the second termin second trans
mark wallberg it was his daughter not
his real daughter in the movie it was
his daughter I don't believe you
so all of this by the way is meaningless
getting back to the bill it's all
meaningless because former by but it
could just he can suspend it he could
just not do it he can just not do it
like oh it's in the best interest of the
United States for me not to do this even
though it's an emergency yeah no huh oh
well and that screws your whole plan
that's like to give you an idea this
actually happened in Canada someone
tried to assassinate our prime minister
in Canada they made it into the house
with a pie no actually no it's even
worse they made it into the house of the
Prime Minister and they took Cutlery
from the prime minister's house they
didn't even show up with a weapon and
they made it to the pister's bedroom and
the wife was like oh crap and closed the
door and that's how it was thwarted and
he had a butter knife and he's
like like it was signs yeah like that
man has that man has a spork let me
close the door that's how useless this
is if someone can just I'll close the
door that's former Vice President Joe
Biden he just like no it it's left up to
his discretion to be clear by the way
just just just I want you to take a
guess how many days over the last year
do you think that we've had more than
5,000 uh encounters how many days how
many days over the last year I'm going
to just I'm going to I'm going to
shortcut it I'm all all no yeah we I
don't even think there was one day that
we didn't have why would you ask me a
question it's a trick question you
already knew the answer okay here's a
fun thinging there he said it could shut
down the border and he can take care of
this problem for us right but he can
only shut it down for a certain number
of days each year and the number of days
that he can shut it down each year is
going down I think it starts at like 270
and it ends up in like the high 100 at
the end which means even though that
provision would be there and we had all
of the days in the last year that had
over 5,000 he couldn't close it down for
all the days over 5,000 well he could he
just chose not to he can't I'm saying
with this bill yeah the bill still
wouldn't allow him to do it no it's
absur there's so many holes there it's
like the border the bill is like the
Border yes exactly well it gets even
worse than that because I know what
you're thinking hey this is a bill to
solve the immigration crisis right
that's harming a lot of Americans not
only through the labor market uh uh but
it's also harming Americans through
Rising crime right across certainly in
southern border states housing market
the housing market of course all these
issues and of course not only help it
cost the taxpayer 120 something billion
dollars a year I believe it's $140
billion a year now last time we did it
when we did the change of my mind it was
15 over 150 that's right it's over 150
billion jez 6 years ago was 116 billion
that's what illegal immigrants cost you
the taxpayer so you think border bill as
it's being called
bipartisan uh this must be about the
Border that's the claim the claim is the
bill is about the border the
truth bll bull just to be clear
okay most of the money is foreign aid so
let's walk through this to the Ukraine
$60
billion $14 billion to Israel another
$2.4 billion the Red Sea conflict uh
when you're talking about Taiwan the
Indo Pacific kind of conflict another 4
billion
now this is $118 billion Bill 20 billion
of which goes to the Border holy
mackerel how how much three times the
amount to Ukraine alone call it the
Ukraine Bill where the Border tossed its
name on there exactly that makes me want
to go
just like a white silver yourself and
eat a carrot
yeah I thought it was a gorilla it was
cagar it cigar pretty close yeah this
cigar that's a bad impression how much
money do you think is in there for
building an actual wall this is a trick
question let zero zero is the answer
here's the thing though here's the thing
here's the thing that they do every
single time we'll talk about this when
as with regards to Reagan and amnesty
first and build the wall later if
there's money left over if yeah then it
goes back to Congress to see if they
actually want to use the leftover funds
to actually build a wall oh
they're going to have $20 billion
Surplus the thing that would keep you
from ever reaching the 5,000 Mark in a
single day of encounters at a non-port
of Entry the wall the only thing that
would is not even being built in this
bill I'll settle for building a wall
around
K just to keep him in just like it's
kevv I've heard I've heard Kev I don't
care it's a country that I don't care
about not the people the country the
country in general I don't like Russia I
don't like Ukraine just to be I know I
get it all of God's children doesn't
apply here yeah they don't believe in
God over there they don't have a god
think about that nothing going to a
border wall 20 billion to the Border
it's called The Border the calling this
the Border Bill yes just go pass your
funding to Ukraine separately Go pass
Israel funding separately Indochina
separately this 20 billion unless it's
to build a wall which by the way 20
billion would do it doesn't matter stop
talking well what the left wants to do
is say look they don't want to solve the
Border problem but what's really
happening is they don't want to
individually propose one other $60
billion for Ukraine because they know
that their constituents would vote them
out they would be incredibly unpopular
so they say it's a border Bill
Republicans won't pass it and
Republicans conservative should be
saying no no it's three times the amount
to Ukraine alone this has nothing to do
with the Border they want to blame you
so they can make you unpopular and they
want to make all of you watching let's
get rid of Representatives you your
point of view unpopular which is why
they're afraid of it which is why
they're afraid of calling this bill the
Ukraine bill because they don't want to
be unpopular because it's fundamentally
dishonest and no one wants to send
another $60 billion to Ukraine yeah well
they did they are spending that $20
billion on something on the border
they're they're actually Building New
Ports of Entry yes where it's going to
be FastTrack citizenship and then right
after you get out of the Port of Entry
boom registration building and it's also
a trick because the the ports of Entry
are just new on the B franchises it's
just Southern nice come on it's mediocre
Mexican food their salsa is good well
they will make it better they will
improve it some of them immigrants some
of them are coming from Africa and won't
do for us but they won their no bid
contract beating out Chi-Chi oh Chichi
sucks is that Chi are great yeah Chichi
were chich they used to have the margar
Tuesday they suck fine let's go to
another claim here they'll try and say
that former Vice President Biden is
powerless to do anything again so he
can't do anything because Republicans
aren't doing anything none of this is me
without this bill and also give me as
president the emergency authorities shut
down the Border until it could get back
under control if that bill were the law
today I'd shut down the border right now
and fix it quickly youd have to okay
okay first off you wouldn't because
here's the truth
former vice president could shut down
the border right now immediately he
could let me give you some let me give
you some precedence he doesn't need new
power yeah 2018 the Supreme Court upheld
president Trump's travel ban Justice
Roberts already said that the president
has the authority to make National
Security judgments related to
immigration just to be clear the
president right now has the authority to
do so he does not he did not he undid a
lot of Donald Trump's executive uh
orders executive actions On the Border
his very first day it was his priority
to undo it number one and just to be
clear this is one one of those issues
that would fall under the legitimate
purview of government to protect you
from internal and external threats and
now it's being left to the states where
it's working in Texas let's look at some
of the you know Eagle Pass By the way
they've taken uh theyve taken some
measures there or as you know many of
you out there call it racist the Eagles
pass uh crossings they went from 3 to
4,000 Crossings a day down to under 200
Crossings a day 3 to 4,000 is almost the
5,000 Mark in one place in one place
that's way too effective St we got to
take down that fence yes exactly
actually you know the Biden
Administration is so committing to
securing our border that they actually
sued the state of Texas and took it all
the way to the Supreme Court to make
sure that they could cut the Raaz of
wire that was actually reducing the
problem by I don't know around 95 99
it's not like they always say look at
how much yeah but hold on a second there
were three to four Crossings in really
one area concentrated area so you could
step in yeah 3 to 4,000 per day what did
I say you said three to four Crossings
which would have been 4,000 3 to 4,000 3
to four you know at some point that's
like a take take an immigrant leave an
immigrant jar
no yeah yeah win some lose some No 3 to
4,000 in one spot per day former Vice
President Biden could have stepped in
shut it down no he didn't so the state
had to take it up and then the federal
government fought the state and it works
these people don't want it to work
because they want to give $60 billion to
Ukraine we could be doing even better
than they're doing at Eagle Pass here's
a summary of former vice president
Trump's sorry I mean to say sitting
president Trump some people call him
former president I call him sitting
president his plan on the border I want
to remind the repu that Donald Trump and
House Republicans also have their own
ideas for the border so let's review the
majority's border ideas that they've
actually
presented here they are Donald Trump
actually has said that he wants to build
alligator Moes along the border that's
one of his incredible ideas I did that
another idea that Donald Trump has
promoted is he actually wants to
Electrify the Border fence and maybe
even put some spikes on the border
that's another
donator majority border R to you got to
keep the alligators out yes it you know
electri the fence this fake news the
spikes were to keep the alligators
in but outside of that pretty close I
did I did do that that's it that's
that's a great idea it's a wildlife
preserve it's it's new culture for
America and frankly at first I wanted
crocodiles because alligators are more
skittish they're like giant squirrels
why couldn't you get crocodiles well
look it's a whole endangered species EG
take it up with Teddy Roosevelt to
National Parks but I wanted Crocs I
couldn't like the plan more it sounds
like securing the Border by whatever
means necessary I love how he thought he
was owning Donald Trump yeah it's like
it's like he goes he had Solutions he's
like we have we could do a wall they're
like no no no we can't do that he's like
all right well how about uh the the
National Guard they're like no we can't
we can't do that how about centes no we
can't do well alligator mod I at like
something electrified fans spikes
alligators yeah I don't know look you
saying the the wall is too expensive you
just dig them out the alligators need
somewhere to go folks they also didn't
talk about his corn maze idea he had a
great corn maze idea and even better
around Halloween it would get spooky you
would end up in
Indiana and You' be like I did I get
here nobody wants that like it's not
just the corn like I feel like it's just
the you don't know where you are for a
week you get turned around someone comes
out with a jump scare and you leave you
end up in
Honduras El Salvador maybe depends on
the season
so here's another truth just to be clear
uh Biden's executive actions on
immigration look it was very clear that
he caused this crisis not always can you
blame someone in a position of power but
January to May 2021 okay he rolled back
right away remain in Mexico the policy
he terminated Trump's uh border
emergency and the Declaration that
existed he diver he diverted border wall
funds he said there's no more emergency
On the Border there's no more emergency
on he just he just get rid of this he's
like yeah there's no more emergency
everything's fine and he didn't just do
this he did it on the day he was sworn
in first day Keystone Pipeline was the
very first thing that he signed and then
he moved right onto this it was the very
first day that he hey hold on a second
he did it your first day when you were
being sworn in when you still picking
out drapes for crying out loud for the
obal office now you can't you can't toss
a little bit of help Eagles pass Eagles
pass over there in Texas he didn't think
he'd be alive this long to be honest
know yeah I think so if you look at the
actuary tables which I know he didn't I
didn't think I was gonna make it and and
don't take my word for it will Lavar
Burton this uh just just hear it from
the illegal immigrants themselves they
wouldn't have crossed under President
Trump did you come here because Joe
Biden was elected president basically
basically uh the main thing was the
violence in my country and the second
thing I think was Joe Biden think about
that for a moment that's an American
basically like you were just behind your
weakness was just behind that guy seeing
his brother's head on a
turtle
that was reason number one and number
two was a shell shock for sure yeah
exactly like you know it's kind of crazy
you see your head on a turtle you know
and it's kind of it's your used to be
your brother and then I like Joe Biden
yeah Joe Biden's going not going to do
anything so I don't have to worry about
my head on a turtle bro oh dude that
guy's American there's no way that was
Mig Abol basically they didn't even name
any country he like H my country it's
sound like I was doing the interview
like ah my country it's like Mexican or
whatever yeah yeah it's vient I just
wanted to cross I just want to climb a
wall you know so let's let's let's wrap
this up here unless I've missed anything
uh bipartisanship of course is not a
virtue that's what they're going to be
saying bipartisan bipartisan bipartisan
okay let's be really clear it's $60
billion for Ukraine it's $20 billion for
the Border uh the bill does not solve
the crisis at all because illegals can
keep coming in in record numbers they
get taxpayer funded lawyers they get
work permit requirements uh eliminated
from this right you get 50,000 uh extra
visas per year uh $20 billion will be
going to I think that's the most
important Point 20 billion to the Border
$60 billion to Ukraine somehow it gets
called the Border bill yeah 100 billion
roughly not going to the Border in this
bill like 17% of the bill is border 17%
I might be wrong by like half or one%
there should be there should be a law
there should be some kind of rule I mean
they make the rules but there should be
some kind of rule that like there's a
percentage that it has to be related to
the title like you call it the blue
skies bill at least 55% needs to be
dedicated keep the sky blue like it's
like okay hold on a second yeah you know
what I'll take the chicken salad
sandwich like okay great don't tell you
that it's actually uh 80% shrimp dude
this was Subway Subway did this with
tuna they found out oh sorry my I don't
give it red okay yeah you think we're
going to be taken out by big Subway oh
is Jared here no my kids are hidden
he's being raped I hope he's getting
ried real hard all Foot Longs he can
handle but yeah they did that they had
like a they found out that their tuna
was like 80% tuna and they're like
What's the other 20 they're like stuff I
don't know but we fixed it yeah like I
don't know well I guess I forgot what
it's like to be you Mr Perfect
Mr Jimmy John and your big game hunting
no Josh it's worse than that it would be
as if 20% of their tuna sandwich was
tuna yes exactly that is actually the
exact opposite now with 20% real
tuna huh approved sorry 175% real tuna
Libby's Juicy Juice 20% juice for 20%
kids
what I'm not buying that I don't think
hey man i' buy that I'd buy that stuff
what would you do with $60
billion probably fight a war I can't win
yeah don't be defeat us for ukrainians
we've already done that yeah I know yeah
they're in Afghanistan territory
anything I missed nope I think we
wrapped it up there you go I I just hope
that that's 60 billion to Ukraine 20
billion of borderers 60 billion to
Ukraine 20 billion of borderers 60
billion to Ukraine 20 billion a border
it's the Border
bill
now well that doesn't include another
country's border I know I really just
needed to say that and that the sponsor
of the bill said the Border never closes
okay 60 billion to Ukraine 20 billion
the border and the Border never closes
done but I want to ensure that you feel
as though you are informed sometimes I
just get a low grade irritation that I
even have to go through it because none
of it matters at this point if the rate
limiting factor is that you don't close
the border and only 20 billion in $118
billion bill goes to the
border so we have our on the ground
correspondent maybe this will we spend
our own money sometimes we're not
necessarily the most prudent with
finances uh Thomas finegan he's actually
at least at the border right now to give
us some insight on the situation of uh
well it's also a big problem just so you
know the human trafficking On the Border
too so this is something we've discussed
and uh we actually wanted to have Thomas
finan we have mug cover get some eyes on
the human trafficking situation how it
affects everyone leaves no no no no
family untouched uh on the ground
correspondent Thomas
finin
Mr finegan what are you seeing down
there hi step yep what are you seeing
what's going on at the human traff well
as you can see behind
me humans in traffic is a serious
problem and it's not just here it's all
over the place I actually have the stats
here that I could go through this is
It's a traffic report of course it is of
course did you really think that today
we're going to be doing a story on
traffic wow Thomas is that what you
thought you thought we were sending you
out
a hey do you want quad for lunch this
is
[Music]
this he's texting me about quad Dias
though those actually don't sound bad
I'd like I mean it's sure I'll take but
that wasn't the point What's the
difference between a quad and a chimy
changa oh chimy changa is like a burrito
like a fried burito deep fried yeah oh
okay what's a tamale a tamale is uh it's
like um it's got this corn mixture in it
it's called Masa and then it's with meat
you put meat with it and then you wrap
it them in a corn husk it's a corn Taco
basically baked basically inside of
anyway delicious the point is let's
let's put a lunch order in I'm getting
hungry I'll take a quesadilla I'll do it
quesadillas are not bad they're
underrated the quesadillas they are you
go some place and not they have like an
extensive menu like you can't screw up
the quadas I think they're actually
perfectly rated yeah yeah I think
they're right where they're supposed to
be on the uh hierarchy of Mexican foods
that's
fair underrated Port changed your mind
overrated you know what I what every now
and then I shoot from the hip I changed
his mind there we
go put it on record I changed Steven
Crowder's mind yeah on it is you got you
had to the I guess you're right you know
what because they have both their
supporters and detractors yeah you know
what's overrated tostadas what's a
tostada ah it's a flat out
with the beans and then the meat and
then you hold it level you have to get a
level you have to get a carpenter and he
has to hold a level and then you have to
eat it without spilling it all over your
place sounds to me like it's largely the
same food but then it's differentiated
by geometry well to is the same thing as
a soapa oh no that's a it's like a giant
nacho okay yeah which is different from
a chimy changa yeah different from a
chimy changa changa changa cha cha ch ch
cha I don't know ch ch cha cha oh boy
all right conf here Tuesday this is why
we need better public schools because we
are the product of
it and so some places are trying right
so let me set this up for you uh in
2020 uh this this person I don't want to
misgender because we're still
technically on YouTube Kai key gross is
the name of this person did you Kai key
Miss gross that's translated from uh
yuck
yes middle name black it was
Scandinavian for
yuck uh this person founded an
organization called quote woke
kindergarten and just to be clear before
we move on here we're going toh talk
about this more on on mug Club because
we just realize there's no good way to
do this if we're still on YouTube uh
lots of money spent actually went
federal funds to this woke kindergarten
initiative and uh scores are worse so
there's a spoiler alert I'm kind of
giving you the end because hey it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey and so here is uh Miss gross in
her own words I believe Israel has no
right to exist I believe the United
States has no right to exist I believe
every settler colony who has committed
genocide against native peoples against
indigenous people has no right to exist
white
supremacy destroys for the sake of
Destruction abolition destroys for the
sake of creation okay hold on we are not
the same just one thing just to be clear
before we move
on I don't like white supremacists okay
everyone here AG Hitler is bad okay
Hitler bad that being said even white
supremacist they don't destroy just for
the sake of Destruction that's why
they're on top they destroy to get rid
of all of the the the minority groups so
that they believe they can build up a
perfect Utopia Hitler didn't just kill
Jews for the sake and Hitler bad for the
sake of Destruction it's because he
wanted to turn it back into what he
believe his great mother Prussia before
him and they could return to their
pre-arrest International stature before
Treaty of vers like in other words to
just misidentify the pro the motive
you're not going to know the problem
just to be and when they say oh white
supremacist tear down they destroyed
just for the sake of Destruction okay as
opposed to and here's the other thing
this is what the left does this is what
woke ideology what Dei what uh what
black liberation theology does they want
to destroy just for the okay so get rid
of the curriculum you get rid of
American history as you want to all
right so you get rid of it and replace
it with
what African history we're going to show
up there and go go oh crap there's more
slaves there's still more slaves over
here they were selling slaves they were
capturing slaves across oh there's by
the way do you hear that sound that's
the sound of the toiling and screaming
of slaves still there today in Africa
African history is easier to teach
because it's the same as African present
yes
exactly you don't have to back check or
anything you just got oh yeah they're
just not selling to the us anymore so
what are you going to do so we you want
to Destro to teach what to teach that
now you have to acknowledge to the point
where I'm like hey let's let them
destroy it let's let them destroy it
because they're like a dog chasing here
you go get rid of American History what
history you're going to teach you know
what let's start with Africa let's go
over to Asia let's go Middle East how
about we go to any other country that
we're talking about continent for crying
out loud more slaves and to this day
more slaves and it makes no sense to say
that white supremacist destroy for the
sake and just to be clear white
supremacists here in this country
they're socialists they are socialists
who believe in all the social safety net
and Welfare programs only they teach
their constituents that it can't work
because of black and brown people and
that's exactly what Hitler did he said
we can have all of these benefits we can
have all of this the these statun
programs we can have the the big big
brother and it's actually good we're
here to help but only white people
throughout history it's not a right-wing
ideology these are socialists who then
base it off of melanin so this person is
teaching children or this person's
program is teaching children and hey is
it any wonder that the literacy rates
the basic functions as far as Matt all
went down because the same person said
white people destroyed just for the sake
of
Destruction I had something to say about
the North and the South earlier we'll
say it in a minute save it for Mud Club
all right so look we're going to
continue with this I'm sure we probably
hit the YouTube dump button at some
point few times if you're watching on
Rumble you can hit that button right
there join mug Club hey none of this
happens without you and your support you
can go mugas for $9 right now and if
you're watching on YouTube I don't what
okay all right you're still on YouTube
kinzinger thank you Rumble you to piss
[Applause]
off